olá meu nome é marcio ballas eu fazia um
programa na band chamada tudo improviso
não sei se alguém já assistiu já viu
depois eu fui pro sbt faz shows e ir à
noite quando eu chego assim quando o
show é só meu
o público foi muito feliz bate palma um
rapa subia o que não rolou aqui né
então como no primeiro tedx estou muito
nervoso eu quero pedir um favor pra
vocês eu queria sair e que quando
voltasse estão muito feliz com a minha
presença tipo nossa surpresa ele nem
estava programa a subir a tirar a roupa
loucura mesmo pode ser eu vou pedir pra
você amiga de faxina na fecomercio nem
você faça na cabeça
ariadne pode tá lindo lindo pra dar uma
animada pode ser legal então vamos de
novo vem
senhoras e senhores com vocês o incrível
márcio barros
ai que delícia
vamos juntar e adnet
ai agora sim ligada tenho mais
espontâneas a cnec
eu sempre posso começar conhecendo o
público então queria começar sabendo o
nome de cada um de vocês que está aí
como tem muita gente eu vou direto ao
assunto eu queria conhecer os homens
levanta a mão só para saber quem são os
homens e as mulheres que é casado tem
filhos
quem é filho quem não entendeu a
pergunta quando é na verdade um grande
filho não quem é de fortaleza mesmo
levanta a mão quem é de fora de
fortaleza algum estrangeiro no público
do rn strangers in the night quem
comandava geladeira ficar seis meses
assim olhando pra dentro levanta a mão
quem já pegou pote de sorvete felizes
não tinha feijão
quem já passou por uma grande mudança na
vida quando eu tinha 17 anos eu tinha
acabado de entrar na faculdade espm em
são paulo e meu pai morreu num acidente
de carro e de uma hora pra outra sem ter
outra opção eu virei turno de papelaria
e durante dez anos foi assim eu tinha um
trabalho normal horário normal salário
normal era tudo normal até que um joão
amigo me falou márcio fazer um curso de
clown um público de que não curte
palhaço de dois dias um fim de semana
sem nem saber o que era eu disse sim
e lá fui eu eu lembro da primeira vez
que eu coloquei um nariz vermelho fechei
os olhos e quando eu abri eu tive essa
impressão que o mundo ao meu redor
estava diferente
eu fiquei muito impactado com aquilo
muito muito aquilo mexeu comigo
quando acabou o curso vai te pegar meu
carro embora eu saí andando pela rua e
mesmo assim eu acho que eu queria
continuar com aquela sensação por mais
tempo
assim foi no dia seguinte foi a primeira
a chegar por último embora eu passei uma
semana sorrindo para o mundo
assim eu fiquei e dois anos depois eu
pra desespero da minha mãe
resolvi largar tudo e deixe a papelaria
rasteirinha pequena poupança vem
meu carro velho e resolvi tentar ser
palhaço profissional
aqui no brasil não tinha curso eu achei
um curso em nova york
de lá eu descobri uma escola em paris e
cole o schakle coke que me aceitou mesmo
meu francês vagabundo e lá fui eu para
frança e um dia um dos meus amigos me
convidou para ir num espetáculo de
improviso o espetáculo de improviso não
existia no brasil eu não sabia o que era
aquilo eu aceitei e fui lá ver
quando cheguei lá eu vi um espetáculo
criado na hora ao vivo o público dava os
títulos e cinco atores criavam a cena na
hora
um dos títulos sorteados foi o meu eu
assistir
eles fazem uma cena onde um dá uma
proposta outro dia sim a outra proposta
dele e outro diz assim a proposta de e
juntos eles criaram uma cena inteira
totalmente improvisada sem nada
roteirizadas em nada ensaiado sem nada
preparado
eu fiquei absolver badoo com aquilo que
me pegou de um jeito
passou mais um tempo eu fiquei lá na
frança e lá eu descobri um grupo chamado
palhaço sem fronteiras
você já ouviu falar dos médicos sem
fronteiras repórteres sem fronteiras
existem também os palhaços sem
fronteiras que fazem inspeções em
lugares em conflito em lugares em guerra
pelo mundo
dois meses depois eu partia na minha
primeira expedição era um palhaço
franceses palhaços ingleses e um palhaço
brazuca
e eu lembro assim a primeira vez a gente
chegando embarcando pela estrada ea
gente já passando por postos de controle
exército casa destruída e chegamos no
campo de refugiados do corvo aquela
chegada foi muito impactante pra mim e
eu estava com muito medo muito muito
medo
primeiro porque era um novato da trupe
segundo porque lá eles falavam albanês e
em terceiro porque estávamos no meio da
guerra e lá pela primeira vez eu pude
experiência na pele essa esse poder que
o palhaço tem de transformar o mundo ao
seu redor
essa capacidade de olhar para o mundo e
jogar com aquilo que se apresenta dia e
sinto aquela situação e jogar com isso o
espetáculo foi incrível
o público amor assim que acabou a gente
fez uma roda em todas todas todas as
pessoas do público e demos um nariz
vermelho pra cada um delas
esse momento foi tão emocionante pra mim
que eu tive que achar um canto escondido
pra chorar
a gente saiu de lá e fizeram questão de
guardar todo nosso cenário acompanha a
gente até a van e eu me lembro agentes
ainda vão embora e escorrendo a gente
dando tchau eles correndo a gente dando
tchau
a volvo embora eles foram ficando para
trás com silêncio ninguém falava nada
fiquei três anos em paris e resolvi que
era hora de voltar ao brasil assim que
eu cheguei no brasil comecei a trabalhar
os doutores da alegria um projeto de
palhaço o hospital não sei se vocês
conhecem e lá novamente eu estava numa
situação totalmente desfavorável à
entrada de um artista no hospital e lá
fui eu no meu primeiro dia de trabalho
como a dupla então cheguei coloquei
minha roupa
meus sapatos meu jaleco me maquiei
peguei meu nariz vermelho e lembrei
daquela vez pela primeira vez que eu
tinha experimentado essa sensação de
colocar o nariz vestir a máscara e fui
trabalhar
tem uma coisa que é muito interessante
que a gente às vezes acha que o palhaço
ele finge que não está no lugar de si o
que ele não faz de conta que não muito
pelo contrário a gente sabe muito bem o
que a gente está fazendo no hospital
nós somos médicos bester holos nosso
trabalho é sério a gente está lá para
trabalhar com qualquer pessoa que vê na
nossa frente uma criança sua família os
profissionais que tiverem lá qualquer
pessoa que cruzar com o nosso olhar
começamos a nossa intervenção e logo no
segundo quarto a gente tem uma
entradinha e uma que fechou assim a cara
no olho pra gente ea mãe festão ok a
gente entendeu o recado
no hospital o palhaço é pode ser
recusado a única figura que atacou a
criança pode dizer não ea gente foi
embora não sem antes
dizer tchau o mais um tal mas o tcheco e
no último tal em sul um leque rio
ele riu e deu tchau pra gente a gente
foi embora assim com aquela sensação de
missão cumprida
quando a gente chegou no final do
corredor a mãe sai do quarto e vem dando
nessa direção a gente olha meio com medo
e ela chega perto a gente começa a
chorar e conta que há três dias que o
menino estava internado
uma tratava os médicos enfermeiras não
queria falar com os pais nem com os
irmãos e depois de três dias
ela viu o filho dela sorrir então ela
chorava abraçavam choravam abraçava a
gente pegou um copo plástico recolheu as
lágrimas caso mais pra frente brasil com
sede ela riu pra gente ri abraçava
chorava e abraçava chorava
brindamos com aquele copo de lágrimas e
fomos embora
o tempo passou com um dos meus parceiros
césar gouveia a gente criou em são paulo
o espetáculo chamado jogando no quintal
uma junção do palhaço e do improviso no
quintal vizinho da casa dele para 40
pessoas
esse projeto com cresceu a gente já fez
para mais de 200 mil pessoas
jogamos em vários países do mundo fomos
campeãs mundiais de improviso na
colômbia pela seleção brasileira e assim
seguir uma carreira e são paulo eu abrir
a casa do amor que é uma escola onde eu
comecei dá cursos e nesses 20 anos e
outro de cursos para diversas pessoas
arquitetos engenheiros eletricistas dona
de casa professores e sempre que as
pessoas davam um feedback para mim eu
ficava muito impressionado com o que eu
recebia e aí eu entendi
vinte anos depois que mais do que uma
linguagem mais do que uma técnica o
palhaço eo improviso são maneiras de ver
o mundo maneiras de olhar para o mundo
uma forma de olhar para a vida o que o
palhaço e o improviso têm em comum o que
eles têm em comum é o olhar do sim olhar
do sim
hoje novo olhar do sim estamos juntos e
ariadne olhar do siri e como é que eu
faço pra ter esse olhar do sim
em primeiro lugar eu digo sim pra mim
você aceitar como você é você aceitar
como você está
então antes de entrar no palco fui lá
inspirei me conectei percebi nosso
nervoso meu coração está acelerado mesmo
tá tremendo respirei me conectei depois
disso eu digo sim para o momento sim pra
que agora você está conectado com o seu
momento presente totalmente ali sabe
quantas vezes na vida você está fazendo
bem as coisas ao mesmo tempo está
começando porque você não está prestando
atenção e é disso que estou falando e
está conectado com a que agora saber
tudo que está acontecendo somente um
tapetinho vermelho aqui na frente de uma
televisão sendo esse lado tem uma luz
ali tem um cronômetro desesperador que
fica baixando 7 19 7 18 7 17
eu preciso saber tudo o que está
acontecendo nesse momento presente e por
último eu digo sim pro jogo jogar
brincar eu digo sinta a situação aceito
aquela minha situação e jogo com ela
isso serve para qualquer pessoa pra
qualquer pessoa normal e por isso eu
queria experimentar fazer um jogo aqui
um exemplo é um exercício aqui
será que alguém topa se voluntariar e
fazer um jogo aqui comigo você ali na
frente pra cá pedir uma sala de parto
nossa voluntário pode ver obrigada
enquanto ele é quem levantou a mão e
disse sim levanta a mão e não levantou a
mão foi desesperado e levanta a mão
quando falei voluntário
quem pensou em levantar mas não teve
coragem levanta a mão
é legal e tem uma coisa interessante do
voluntário porque quando eu pergunto
voluntário acontece uma coisa que chama
de fernandão tatu-bola que a pessoa vai
entanto podem no entanto a dentro pra
dentro e ela fica muito feliz quando
chega um voluntário elas a área tudo bem
como é o seu nome
felipe e felipe e se faz o que é felipe
fotógrafa fotógrafo philip vou fazer um
jogo com você pra isso
só que apenas você diga sim eu vou pedir
coisas se aceita não tem errado não tem
certo você só tem que dizer sim setor
sem dizer se você só tem que dizer sim
ele só tem de dizer exatamente felipe
você é fotógrafo sim legal
senhoras e senhores muito prazer meu
nome é phillip eu sou fotógrafo
eu uso óculos porque eu não vejo bem
porque é uma lenda que eu gosto de ver o
mundo através das lentes
se tem uma qualidade minha que eu vou
dizer que eu sou o destemido e temido a
quando alguma coisa é o tchan
eu sempre erro eu desde pequenininho eu
temia todo mundo entendeu que o meu
sonho sempre foi viajar pra argentina as
pessoas da argentina mas à minha custa
los argentinos e eu comprei uma passagem
mas não vou falar que a via não vou
falar de um ônibus época só pobre membro
então lá eu pego o ônibus e quatro dias
depois cheguei na argentina quando
cheguei a gente não encontrei o meu
professor foi lá que tá lá ele foi aí
mano beleza que era brasileiro mesmo
assim fiquei muito feliz na argentina o
tempo natal realizado quando abri a
porta do hotel ela fez barulho aqui ó de
um gatinho dentro da média recebido aí
joguei bate bem longe e ele foi pra lá
eu abri a janela do meu hotel
o gatinho sai daqui gatinho e aí ouvi o
barulho do vento e eu estava perto do
estádio reparo do estádio inclusive a
bola
e assim foi o meu dia e eu terminei
falando uma poesia que minha mãe sempre
dizia começar com a letra a à coletiva
uma lesma pela politran a eu estou com
um pouco de gripe mas eu estou feliz e
meu nome é felipe massa de pa
obrigado você legal legal percebem uma
cena só é criada porque o filipe disse
sim para as minhas propostas
eu digo sim para as idéias dele e vocês
disseram sim pra gente e agora eu queria
pedir para vocês
ah eu deixei narizes vermelhos nas
cadeiras vocês eu quero que vocês se
conhecem na mão no nariz
segura na mão e similares e vou pedir
pra vocês fecharem os olhos por um
segundo
feche os olhos no segundo o segundinho e
vou pedir pra vocês terem sido pra você
conecta com você conecta com seu corpo
sua respiração e agora de olhos fechados
ou pedir para vocês colocarem o nariz
vermelho fest a máscara a menor máscara
do mundo não abra os olhos ainda eu vou
contar 3216 vão abrir os olhos no 321
abre os olhos e olha para esse universo
se apresentou para pequenas coisas
olha para as pessoas ao lado olha no
olho mesmo é isso
agora vou pedir pra vocês voltarem olha
pra cá de novo eu queria dividir com
vocês um sonho que eu tive eu imaginei
imagina você se acorda um dia tá todo
mundo de palhaço
todo mundo é palhaço você sai da sua
casa na rua todo mundo é palhaço
o cara da padaria um motorista do ônibus
o cobrador
você chega no seu trabalho a
recepcionista palhaça a moça do
cafezinho todos os colegas seu chefe o
ciee é o da empresa é palhaço
aí você volta pra casa um outro táxi é
palhaço o zelador do prédio palhaço no
elevador seus três vezes e nunca cruzou
olhar são palhaços mas se abre a porta
da sua casa a sua esposa linda palhaça
se abraça ela aí vêem seus filhos e seus
filhos não estão de palhaço eles não
estão de palhaço
e sabe porquê porque eles são palhaços
eles são palhaços a verdade é que todos
nós somos palhaços
todos nós somos improvisadores da vida
todos nós nascemos com esse olhar
então que tal se a gente trouxesse esse
olhar de volta para as nossas vidas
muito obrigado
o gol